una manera de formar éter es es usando
la síntesis de williamson en la que
comenzamos con un alcohol y añadimos una
base fuerte para despertar el alcohol
una vez de protón ado el alcohol
añadimos un haluro de alquilo los
alumnos de alquilo primarios funcionan
mejor hablaremos de por qué en un minuto
y lo que ocurre es que terminas
colocando el grupo r prima del allure o
de alquilo en lo que antes era el
alcohol para formar un éter así
veamos el mecanismo para la síntesis de
williamson en la que empezamos con un
alcohol
sabemos que los alcoholes funcionan como
ácidos débiles
entonces si hace reaccionar un alcohol
con una base fuerte
algo como hidruro de sodio
sabemos que la porción hidruro de la
molécula va a funcionar como una base
fuerte este par de electrones
disponibles va a tomar ese protón que va
a empujar estos electrones hacia el
oxígeno
si dibujamos el producto de esa reacción
ha sido base tenemos ahora un oxígeno
con tres pares de electrones disponibles
alrededor dándole una carga formal
negativa de -1 lo llamamos una unión al
coc sido que interactuar ya con el lyon
sodio
positivamente cargado que flota
alrededor hay algo de interacción
electrostática iónica entre esas cargas
opuestas y es aquí cuando introducimos
el allure o de alquilo si dibujamos
nuestro alumno de alquilo
se vería así
y sabemos que hay una diferencia en
electrónica tividad entre el halógeno y
el carbón o el halógeno va a ser
parcialmente negativo y el carbono va a
ser parcialmente positivo
carbon o parcialmente positivo significa
que ese carbono quiere electrones va a
funcionar como un electro filo en el
siguiente paso del mecanismo y un par de
electrones disponibles en el oxigeno va
a funcionar como un núcleo filo cargas
opuestas se atraen un par de electrones
disponibles en el núcleo filo va a
atacar a nuestro electro filo el carbono
al mismo tiempo los electrones en el
enlace entre el carbono y el halógeno
van a irse al halógeno así este es un
mecanismo tipo s n 2 este es un
mecanismo tipo
n 2 por lo que un alumno de alquilo
primario funcionará mejor ya que tiene
un menor impedimento estético comparado
con otros saludos de alquilo entonces lo
que ocurrirá es después del ataque
núcleo físico vamos a unir al oxígeno
con el carbono así y formamos nuestro
éter
si quisiéramos podríamos volver a
dibujar al éter así para mostrar que le
añadimos un grupo r prima de esta manera
veamos un ejemplo de la síntesis de
williamson si comienzo con una molécula
aquí del lado izquierdo
es una molécula que se ve interesante se
llama beta astol
y ventanas tool tiene dos anillos juntos
así y luego tiene un h
unido a estos anillos de esta manera
esta es beta nafta
y en la primera parte vamos a añadir
hidróxido de potasio en el primer paso
hidróxido de potasio como base el
hidróxido de potasio no es una base tan
fuerte como el hidróxido de sodio pero
en este caso está bien usar una base un
poco débil entonces el par de electrones
disponibles en el hidróxido van a tomar
a ese protón dejando estos electrones
atrás en el oxígeno
cuando dibujamos la base con jugada de
ventanas tool
podemos mostrarla
vamos a tomar el pse protón que va a
dejar ese oxígeno
con tres pares de electrones disponibles
dándole una carga formal de menos 1 este
es nuestro año al cocido
y este año nalco óxido presenta
estabilidad por resonancia una base con
jugada con estabilidad por resonancia
estabiliza a la base con jugada lo que
hace al beta nafta un mejor ácido que
otros alcoholes de los que hablaremos
adelante dado que él ve tan ashton es un
poco más ácido está bien que usemos una
base más débil para este ejemplo
entonces el hidróxido de potasio es
suficientemente fuerte para tomar el
protón ácido en el beta nafta porque la
base conjugada del ventanas toll
presenta estabilidad por resonancia en
el segundo paso una vez que hemos
formado nuestro año analco óxido es aquí
cuando añadimos nuestro al 1 d al kilo
si añado mi haluro de alquilo en el
segundo paso veamos si podemos tener
suficiente espacio aquí voy a usar
yoduro de metilo como nuestro al duro
alquilo yoduro de metilo así y
nuevamente sabemos que este carbono va a
ser el carbono electro físico entonces
entonces núcleo filo electro filo un par
de electrones disponibles en el oxígeno
ataca al carbono empuja a estos
electrones hacia el yodo y formamos
nuestro producto vamos a dibujar el éter
producido resultante estos anillos van a
permanecer iguales así
y ahora vamos a tener un oxígeno unido a
un grupo metilo que vino del yoduro de
metilo así
entonces formamos nuestro producto
este producto se llama aerolína que es
un fijador usado en el perfume tiene un
aroma interesante si alguna vez tienen
la oportunidad de hacer esta síntesis de
williamson es muy interesante ver cómo
huele la aerolína como se ve y pensar en
ella como un componente de algunos
perfumes pensemos en sintetizar un éter
si les dieran un problema en el que la
pregunta dijera algo como aquí está el
éter que quiere sintetizar
que necesitarías para poder hacerlo
necesitas pensar bien este es mi éter y
lo voy a formar a partir de otras cosas
y se analizan los grupos al kilo unidos
a meter tengo un grupo metilo de este
lado y esto sería un grupo ciclo xxi lo
de este lado y uno de esos dos grupos lo
voy a usar para mi alumno de alquilo
quieres usar el grupo que tenga menor
impedimento estético ya que es un
mecanismo tipo s n 2 para ello es
preferible el grupo metilo en el segundo
paso
necesitarías usar algo como yoduro de
metilo
tiene menor impedimento estético por lo
que mejorará tu rendimiento en esta
reacción
ese es el segundo paso y en el primer
paso
tienes que agregar una base fuerte por
lo que usaremos y bruno de sodio
y por lo tanto tu alcohol debe de venir
de aquí tu alcohol debe de venir
aquí
entonces si voy a mostrar mi alcohol
inicial tendría que verse así
y le añado a ese alcohol en mi primer
paso y duro de sodio como ese protón
formó un alcohol sido ese alcohol sido
hace un ataque núcleo físico al yoduro
de metilo para añadir el grupo metilo y
formar el éter del lado derecho entonces
así es como se piensa en usar la
síntesis de williamson piensen en retro
síntesis y piensen piensen en qué grupo
alquilo es el mejor para usar en saludo
de al kilo